>>
[Clapping]
John Micklethwait: Thank you very much.
As Mark said, I'm happy to answer questions
about almost as many things as God, but with
slightly less omniscience.
I'm going to employ two cheap tricks, and
the first is to claim that my aim today is
to have a conversation.
For those of you -- I know Peter Barron here
-- for those of us who've covered politics,
the phrase anybody standing in front of you
claiming they want to have a conversation
is more or less suicidal, because there is
no more vacuous phrase in politics.
It's usually an excuse for somebody who has
nothing at all to say.
There was a moment the other day when Gordon
Brown began a speech with that phrase, which
made me almost inherently worry about what
he was up to.
But in this particular time, my aim was to
talk probably about 25 minutes about the idea
of this book and the idea of "God is back.”
And then, open up to conversation, both in
terms of If you would ask about the book,
but also If you want to ask about broader
things.
As I said, I'm happy to answer about anything
other than really, technology.
I think I'll begin with where the book begins.
And the book begins in a sitting room -- a
little smaller than this.
About half the size of this room -- in Shanghai.
It's owned by a man who -- for the sake of
argument -- we'll call Wang, who is a young
Chinese man who works for a company, which
I've probably described as a competitor/partner
of Google's.
Who we don't identify.
In the room gathered, there's a couple of
academics, there's couple of scientists who
work on stem cells, there's two CEOs, someone's
just flown in from Philadelphia, where he
was away for the weekend.
What we're in is a house church in Shanghai.
And this is the center of -- what I would
argue is -- the most remarkable religious
explosion, arguably in some ways, since the
very beginnings of Christianity in the Roman
Empire.
Already, China, I would argue, has as many
as 100 million Christians.
There are certainly more members -- more people
going to church each week in China -- than
there are members of the Communist Party,
around 70 million members of the Communist
Party.
Why is this source of strength -- the source
of power -- why has it cropped up?
Because you go to a house church.
What they do is they spend about two to three
hours sitting there reading one bit of a text
and then discussing it.
It's admirably high-tech to some extent.
It's full of new gadgets.
They use computers.
They use the Internet to download hymns.
And they talk repeatedly -- mainly led by
this guy, who as I said, we'll call Wang.
And he goes in very, heavy detail for a particular
bit.
But there's a group of people who are obsessed
by this.
Why is China suddenly discovering religion
in such a big way?
I think it's partly -- and this is a sort
of theme which will crop up repeatedly throughout
this talk -- it's partly a kind of demand
for meaning.
You have a country which has gone through
an enormous change.
One statistic about China -- I'm going to
slightly mess it up -- I think in one year,
1997 or 1998, more people moved from the countryside
to the cities in China than crossed the Atlantic
in the century before 1920.
So, you have more social dislocation than
before.
You have a vacuum where there is not much
meaning at all, in the sense that the Communist
ideology has gone, but people want something
new to structure their lives around.
And this comes through very, very firmly in
the house churches.
But it's also, I think, a question of supply.
It's to do with the fact that the Internet
is providing ever new ways to reach it.
It's to do with the fact that US-style missionaries
are rushing around China trying to spur faith
forwards -- either Americans or else Koreans,
particularly, are pushing it.
It's also bizarrely -- and this, I think,
goes to the apex of our book, which is about
religion and politics -- it's also a lot to
do with government policy.
Because the interesting thing about that room
is, I think, in that case there were 26 people
in the room.
But there is a policy in China -- a rule -- which
says that whenever any meeting gets to 25
people, beyond that you need government permission.
And what the Chinese government has done,
almost single handedly -- the only previous
people who I think have done this were actually
the Roman emperors -- was by setting a limit
on how many people can gather together, they
have hit the most explosive means of growing
religion yet known.
Because the moment they get to about 24, 25,
26, neighbors begin to complain, people go
for the car spaces outside.
It's more routine things like that, rather
than people actually getting really angry
about it.
And the house church automatically splits.
And so, the one I went to, within a couple
of weeks, it split up into two.
One of them was sited -- went back to the
American company where -- meets in the American
company where Wang works.
And each time it splits, it grows.
And that is what is pushing it ahead.
More generally I think -- what's interesting
-- and the reason we begin with Wang, is
not just because it's fascinating that religion
is growing so rapidly in a place that was
thought to have got rid of it completely.
And it's not just Protestantism, but it is
mostly that.
It's also to do with the fact that this is
beginning to impact politics.
Because, if you talk to the Chinese leadership,
they are in a deeply-divided position over
this amazing phenomenon, which is happening
within their borders.
One part of them, is very -- I suppose -- pleased
about the idea that there is a sort of social
glue developing.
There's something that they can use to bond
their country together.
They're conscious of the fact that religion
is useful to that extent.
Indeed, if you look at the official pronouncements
-- people like Hu Jintao -- they've gone
from Mao, despising, cursing religion, driving
people out, killing priests, killing anyone
who came towards them -- towards an official
policy at least of welcoming them, of having
established churches, which are still relatively
small.
There's around 20 million people.
The official statistics show in China that
around -- I think it's 25 million -- now go
to church each week.
Those are the people going to the established
churches.
By any guess, the people going to house churches
are three or four times as big.
So, it's purely a matter of how much you measure
it.
But there are official churches.
They separate Christians from Catholics, which
is an interesting division.
That is the way in which they choose to do
it.
One half of official China is welcoming religion.
The other half is deeply frightened by it.
Why?
Because in Chinese history, religion -- particularly
Christian religions -- have always been created
with difficulty.
You have the Taiping Rebellion back in the
19th century.
They also strangely, I think, give the pope
-- perhaps Pope John Paul II, slightly greater
credit than many outsiders would do for his
role in bringing down the Soviet Empire.
Above all though, it's a question of a big,
social organization.
Already, as I said, the Chinese church is
bigger than the Communist Party.
It's also already pretty close to being the
largest NGO in the country.
These people are beginning to set up schools,
they're doing some health care.
They're already a force within the country.
And, if the Chinese government was already
worried about Falun Gong, the idea of a group
of people with such a clear connection to
the West -- is, I think, difficult for them.
And so, they split between those two feelings.
One half of them desperate to kind of cling
on -- to use religion for social purposes.
The other bit deeply upset about what it could
do.
And that is very much what this book is about.
This book is about, on the one hand, saying,
"Wake up," if you're in Western Europe.
Because basically, whether we like it or not
-- and this is not a book written to either
propagate or denounce religion -- wake up,
because around the rest of the world, religion
is doing extremely well.
But that brings with it political consequences,
both good and bad.
If in ten years time you read about Chinese
Christians helping usher in a new thing of
democracy in China, well, that would be good.
If, on the other hand, you see very fierce
clamp-downs and difficulties, well, that is
perhaps less persuasive.
I should stress that the title of this book
is very much a conclusion, not a thesis that
we took into it.
It's basically, at its core, a work of journalism.
It was two people who originally thought about
writing a book about religion in America.
And then we started from the presumption that
America looked something of an exception.
But then, when you actually look at the numbers.
Actually the whole question, the whole ideology,
which I deny it being -- it had been brought
up by one atheist, the other was Catholic
-- the ideology in which we've been brought
up in was the idea that religion was bound
to disappear.
And yet, you look around the world, and that
just isn't true.
It's true of Western Europe; it's not true
of everywhere else.
Indeed, religion on the whole, is doing -- if
anything -- rather better.
The proportion of people belonging to the
main religions has risen from roughly 60 percent
to 70 percent even in the conditions when
people thought it was going backwards.
You look at Asia, you look at Latin America,
you look at Africa, and this book essentially
is a journalistic foray going around the world
and reporting back what exactly we saw.
And, in fact, it gets more difficult than
that for the tradition in which we were brought
up in -- this idea that, whether we liked
it or not, religion was bound to go down.
There are two other very strange things which
are happening around the world.
Firstly, the wrong sorts of religion are the
ones doing well.
In the 60's and 70's -- certainly when I was
being taught -- the general assumption was
that any kind of religions which would survive,
would be the sort of -- the cleverest sort.
They'd be ones where you'd have sort of Graham
Greene-ish doubting Catholicism.
You would have very clever Anglicanism, which
managed to accommodate to all the new sort
of fluxes of society.
In fact, on the whole, it tends to be the
most emotional ones -- Islam to some extent.
But you've also got the push of Pentacostalism.
Pentacostalism -- Wang was one of them -- is
the most successful religion of the past century.
It started in the back streets of Los Angeles
in 1908.
There are now as many as 600 million, 700
million Charismatics or Renewalists around
the world.
This is the most emotional form of religion.
I've been to an exorcism in Brazil, which
I'm happy to describe.
It is not necessarily something based around
the mind.
And to make it even more difficult for those
apostles of secularism -- the whole idea in
which we were brought up in -- is the wrong
sort of people are flooding towards religion.
It's not -- as is often depicted even occasionally
on, or used to even occasionally be on organizations
like the BBC -- if you go to America, megachurchs
are not being set up in the middle of nowhere,
run by useless hicks in the deeper, darker
bits of North America.
They are in the gleaming suburbs beside malls
with Tiffanies and whatever.
And it's the same pretty much around the world.
The people in Wang's church were not the people
who are at the bottom of Chinese society.
They were the people struggling to go to the
top.
If you look at Hindu, if you look at the rise
of the BJP in India, you look at the growth
of the AK party in Turkey, again you see exactly
the sort of prosperous bourgeoisie -- which
the very secular founders of India and Turkey,
Ataturk and Naru -- exactly the people they
wanted to create.
It would cast aside all the suspicion.
They are exactly the people who are rushing
towards religion.
So, what is going on?
And we argue really, it's a tale of two revolutions.
The first one is the French.
And that was a revolution against the Ancien
regime.
And it was a revolution very much against
the church as well.
And that European tradition -- of seeing progress
heading in one direction and religion heading
in another -- was being, I think, carried
forward, by the intellectuals who've dominated
this debate ever since.
If you think of the tradition I was brought
up in of Freud, Marx, Darwin, Nietzsche.
All these people repeatedly push forward the
idea that religion was to move to the side.
And the interesting thing is that -- almost
exactly the same time as you have the French
Revolution, you had the American Revolution,
which whatever it was, was not remotely against
religion.
The interesting point about American religiosity
-- and really what we're saying is that American
religion, which is going to be the dominant
form, not necessarily, I'm not saying the
world is going to go universally Christian
or universally evangelical -- the equivalent
if you want, of Google, in -- I don't believe
I'm saying this -- the equivalent of a leading,
software company dominating its particular
niche, is actually American religiosity.
That is the one.
That is the model which the Chinese are copying.
It's the model which is pushing through Latin
America.
It's the model which is pushing through Africa.
And it's the model which, I think, will probably
have some run in Europe.
And if you look at where that came from, it
didn't really exist before the American Revolution.
If you go before the American Revolution,
America is basically just as useless as Europe
when it comes to revolution.
So it comes to religion.
There was an established church.
Things weren't going particularly well.
Even Salem, the place which Miller used for
"The Crucible".
There, 83 percent of households had no religious
identification.
And the reason why is that, we always have
this vision of America as this place set up
by puritanical starters.
By the founding fathers -- not by the founding
fathers -- by the original kind of Mayflower
lord.
Well, that's true.
The original lot were kind of these die-hard,
religious fanatics.
The people who came straight afterwards were
often people who went there -- some of them,
many of them were sent there against their
will.
There was a vast amount of young men who would
have gone to prison or perhaps, even to Australia
in later times, but were then sent to America.
These were not people who were remotely interested
in religion.
The American religion, all the bishop's letters.
There were one or two "Great Awakenings,"
as they were called, but by and large, America
didn't seem that different to Europe.
And why did it change?
It changed, I think, because of two documents.
If you need to understand why religion can
spread, why it does work, you really only
need two documents to understand it.
The first is the U.S. Constitution, because
the U.S.
Constitution had that brilliant idea of "separating
church from state.”
And what happened in America was, before they
did that, there wasn't competition.
Once they did do that, it changed dramatically.
The Methodists, for instance, converted around
an eighth of the country within a generation,
because they were able to get out there.
Their people who were Methodist ministers
were not pushed to -- they didn't rely on
establishment to keep pushing them up.
On this side of the Atlantic, in Britain,
the Methodists were always in a bit of difficulty
about how they dealt with an established church
-- whether they were on the inside of the
political system, whether they were outside.
And in America, they were just another faith
competing against others.
And that brings me to the second document,
which I think explains an enormous amount,
which is Adam Smith's "Wealth of Nations.”
People forget that there is part of that which
deals with this.
There's a brilliant discussion between Adam
Smith who looked and said, "Wherever you have
an established clergy, you're not going to
have religion doing particularly well.”
And David Hume, who read this, and was utterly
horrified by this, because he loathed religion,
very much came from that early tradition.
And he begged Smith not to include it, because
he said, "Once people at the Church of England
read this, they'll realize how stupid they
are, and they'll start having the American
system of competing religions.”
But Smith persevered, not for the last time.
And, if you look at what's happened in America,
you see a relentless succession of waves.
You have the Methodists first, but then you
have the Baptists.
Catholics, actually, in America competed amazingly
successfully, because they weren't really
an established church.
And you see that all the way through to the
Pentecostals now.
And what you're now seeing around the world
is that phenomenon has gone global like so
many other ones.
Pentacostalism, as I mentioned, you can go
to all sorts of places and see amazing things
going on.
If you want to look at big mega-churches,
five out of the ten biggest ones in the world
are in Korea.
I went to one where there's about 800,000
people.
They're members of one church.
It's almost like attending a massive football
match, several times over, on a Sunday of
legions of ushers taking you to different
bits.
And it is approached -- and one has to be
rather crude about saying this -- with just
as relentless a devotion to marketing and
just as relentless a devotion to customer
segmentation as you'd find in many parts of
any other sort of business.
There are churches for bikers.
There are churches for gays.
There are churches for dropouts.
There's a "Scum of the Earth Church" in Colorado.
There are Bibles for soldiers, Bibles for
teens, Bibles for tweens, Bibles for people
in one form of emotional distress, Bibles
for rappers.
"Even though I walk through the hood of death,
I don't back down, for you have my back,"
is one selection.
[laughter] You can go to Golgotha Fun Park.
And these, as I say, it's not just American
and Christian.
But that is the dominant, I think, gene in
terms of the way the religious market around
the world is being steered.
You can see the same thing in terms of, Islamic
mega-preachers are beginning to pick up the
same habits the Christian ones do.
If you go to Hindu temples in India, you will
actually discover a sort of high-tech efficiency
of a level I would argue that's even greater
than you see in the rest of religion.
So, to some extent, that's the supply side
of what's happening.
The demand side -- I think, a lot of it comes
from the big, economic movement of our time,
which remains I think globalization.
Globalization creates demand for religion
in two senses.
One is the one, which most critics are only
too keen to point out is, it creates demand
for storm shelter against change.
And I think that is true.
I'm not remotely denying that.
You go to places, you go to Arkansas, but
you can also go to the suburbs of Cairo, and
you can find a lot of people who are clinging
to religion, because they see that as a protection
against the on-rush of the modern -- in some
cases -- very American world.
But at the same time, I think for many, many
more people, it's -- at least the modern versions
of religion are being seen as a way to get
ahead.
I don't think it's any accident that the best-selling
book about religion in America, by miles,
best-selling book of any sort pretty much
in modern times, is a book called "The Purpose
Driven Life," by Rick Warren.
It's about people looking for meaning.
It's about people who sit there and think
that their life has reached a certain point
that they want some kind of framework to understand
it.
And the reason why -- and again, this is looked
at from outside objectively -- is that man,
whether we like it or not -- and this is really
what we have to confront, particularly people
who just assume that religion was going to
fade away -- was that man is fundamentally
a thixotropic creature.
It's something which man generally will be
brought back to religion.
And it is also -- again, whether we like it
or not -- a rational thing to do, because
religious people -- and again, the numbers
in America are pretty convincing about this.
Religious people tend to be healthier; they
live longer.
They tend to be wealthier; they're better
off than other people.
And they tend to be wiser.
They tend to be better educated.
And what's interesting about science for the
moment, is while you have one group of scientists
who are going out producing ever-more, elaborate
evidence as to why God didn't exist at all,
and differences, and stuff like black holes
and so on.
You have a whole other bevy of social scientists
who are going out looking at the reasons why
religion actually seems to work or does quite
well.
And you have weird experiments where you put
nuns and Buddhist monks into MRI machines
-- not at the same time --
>> [Laughter]
John Micklethwait: -- to measure what their
brains are doing when they listen, when they're
praying.
You have people looking at -- vast number
of economists looking at -- why religious
communities seem to work as an organization,
and so on, and so on.
So this, in a sense, is the world in which
I think we now have to live in.
And understanding that world, and suddenly
taking into account that there is a different
sort of form of reality in most of the world,
particularly for people in Western Europe
where things are not going that direction,
I think, is something that we have to deal
with.
Is it a good world?
Well, I'd argue to one extent, from the point
of view of a liberal editing a liberal paper,
it is -- although a bit of a deeply secular
one -- I would say it is a good one, because
it's fundamentally based around choice.
Modernity.
And this, I think, is the big category mistake.
This is the huge mistake which most of the
apostles of secularization made.
They identified modernity with secularism.
And it isn't.
Modernity is really about pluralism.
It's about the ability to sit there and decide
and choose, "I'm going to be this," "I'm going
to be that," or "I'm going to be whatever.”
And that I think is the core liberal thing
to do it.
But if you have a choice -- and this comes
on to the political part of the book -- choice
has consequences.
In some cases, the consequences are good;
in other cases, they're less good.
If you decide, if you look at America, one
out of every four people changes their faith
during their life.
Close to one out of two, if you divide different
forms of Protestantisms into different sorts.
America is a place where people are changing
their religion all the time.
They're choosing to do things.
They're not necessarily just walking into
the same church their parents did, and starting
from six and going all the way up to 70.
If you start choosing -- as an increasing
number of people are around the world -- what
kind of religion you're going to do, you are,
I would maintain, much less likely to leave
that set of beliefs behind when you enter
the ballot box, whether you go to the workplace,
whether you go anywhere outside.
It's becoming an act of choice, rather than
one of inheritance.
And that, I think, does have big consequences.
It's plainly good in some cases, in terms
of the effects of what religion can do.
If you go to a town like Philadelphia, for
instance, you see actually if you took away
all the social services that religious people
provide, you'd effectively have to find about
$500 million a year more money from the state
in order to provide things.
One reason why religion has not done so well
in Europe is partly because the state does
do more things than it does in America.
I think the world where -- ____ I think I've
used in this respect, is it a fair example
-- the world where religion poisons everything,
I think does not stand up to consequences.
Certainly, I'm one who's wandered around the
world and looked at all the horrors and good
things that religion does.
It's patently obvious that a huge amount of
good work gets done which otherwise would
not be done because of people who are religious.
But there is also equally obviously bad consequences
of the spread of religion.
I think, particularly, this was the area that
Europeans -- unlike the Americans -- were
right to be worried about.
One reason why Europeans turned against religion
is because they associate it with wars of
religion.
I think there are two particular areas which
stand out and which are likely, I think, to
haunt politics for the future.
The first is "wars of religion" and the second
are "culture wars.”
What do I mean by "wars of religion?”
I thought I would read out a speech by Mahmoud
Ahmadinejad to Iran's Parliament quite recently.
He asked, "Who are our enemies, and why do
they hate us?”
And his answer was that Iran faced an axis
of evil with its enemies being, I quote, "All
the wicked men of the world, whether abroad
or at home.
And the root cause of their hatred," he told
the Iranians, "was their loathing.
The root cause of the opponent's hatred was
a loathing of whomsoever should serve the
glory of God.”
And he goes through all George Bush's atrocities.
And then he tells the cheering MPs, "Truly,
your great enemy is the American.
Through that enmity that is in him against
all that is of God in you.
Fortunately," he said, "Iran wouldn't fight
alone.”
It had the support of Muslims around the world.
"Be bold," he advised, "and you will find
that you act for a very great many people
that are God's own.”
Now, the interesting thing about that speech
was, it wasn't actually given by Mahmoud Ahmadinejad.
It was given by Oliver Cromwell in 1656.
And he was reaching out to English Puritans,
rather than Iranian Muslims.
In that case, the Great Satan was not George
Bush, but Catholic Spain.
That was the time of the 30 Years War Retirement,
incidentally, when more people died in that
religious conflict than they did in the Great
Plague.
I think now, if you are going to be worried
about what religion could do to the world,
I think there are similar worries to some
extent.
The most obvious one is, you have to look
at the big conflicts that could rip apart
our world.
I think you could say three out of the four
are actually -- got a very, very strong religious
component.
And those four, I would say, were Israel/Palestine,
India/Pakistan, America/Iran, and North Korea.
Only North Korea, I think, strikes me as a
totally secular one.
If you look at terrorism, once again, we're
living in a world which Cromwell, I think,
would have found distinctly worrying and indeed
familiar.
One of the most interesting things to me is,
if you look at that videotape of Mohammad
Sidique Khan talking about prior to going
off to go bomb on 7-7, the parallels between
that and Guy Fawkes back in 1604 are actually
terrifying even down to the fact they both
speak in the same Yorkshire accent.
One of them is the fact -- it's the essence
of the man who went overseas to get even more
radicalized than he was when he left and then
came back with the aim of committing a huge
act of terrorism.
At the same time, other cynics would point
out that the other problem we have, which
is the same as Cromwell, is we have a great
religion and schism or in crisis.
We have the split between Sunni and Shia in
Islam, and we have the ramifications of that
just as we have the ramifications of Christianity
back in the 16th century.
I would still say it's not remotely as bad
as that, because we no longer have leaders
who are pulling us towards this.
It tends to be much more a bottom-up dispute.
It tends to be much more an issue of people
coming from down below pushing things up,
whereas back then, you had a question of princes
actually leading people into army under religious
banners.
But, what is clear and what is identical is
that once you get religion into a dispute,
it is much, much harder to solve.
If you want a perfect example of that, look
at Israel/Palestine.
You go back to the beginning of the Israeli/Palestinian
dispute, you have Israel set up by pretty
secular Jews, particularly David Ben-Gurion
who gave the sort of religious lot something
to hang onto, but basically the tone of the
original Israel was very secular.
The Palestine Liberation Organization for
a long time was headed or led by Christians
in fairly prominent positions.
Now, you have two sides who are at their most
radical.
Both believe that God gave them a particular
area of the world, and that makes compromise
much, much more difficult.
And the same, I think, applies to culture
wars.
Most places have managed to reach a sort of
fuzzy compromise.
They have issues like abortion.
If you believe either that abortion is murder
-- or for that matter, on the other side,
I suppose if you believe it is a fundamental
right of every single person -- it's much,
much more difficult to compromise.
And that brings me to the second sort of wars
which I think are coming up which are these
culture wars.
I think exactly the same thing that we saw
in America is going to some extent come here.
I don't necessarily mean abortion, but I do
think technology is pushing us towards issues
like stem cells, like cloning, which are going
to have an effect in Europe.
I think also we see the growth of Islam here
is causing many of the same arguments that
we thought have been dispatched two centuries
ago to rearrange.
What exactly is the role of particular services?
Do people need different forms of justice
systems?
You have the issue of sharia.
You have the issue of whether the country
can tell you what to wear through head scarves,
and so on.
And again, I think, what's interesting about
this is that it has crept up on us.
Because, even in America, what is interesting
is, the politicians who have to deal with
this, even bizarrely, quite religious politicians
themselves, never actually really saw this
element of foreign policy coming up.
Religion was a bit of foreign policy that
everybody ignored, that nobody really saw.
There's a wonderful Madeline Albright anecdote
about a Clinton cabinet meeting where one
of them suddenly says, "Isn't it amazing.
It's incredible.
It's the end of the 20th century, and we're
still discussing a religious dispute in Northern
Ireland.”
And the general assumption is this was the
last possible version of this before finally
that episode of diplomacy was thrown away.
That was only two years before September 11th.
I think what's interesting to me is that,
if you look at those two issues.
One, the culture wars at home.
Secondly, these possible wars of religion
between places.
I think both, to some extent, lead back to
America.
They lead back to America, because first,
in terms of foreign policy, I think it is
America which is the one which has to do most.
I think, fundamentally, you are never going
to have a settlement of the sort of disputes,
which I mentioned earlier, if you don't involve
religious people in it.
If you look at Northern Ireland, what's interesting
is, they actually did bring priests and vicars
into the discussion.
What happened on British television -- for
those of you old enough to remember -- was,
whenever any atrocity happened, you saw both
a Catholic priest and a Protestant rector
condemning the same atrocity regardless of
which side it was.
You go to Jerusalem, you do not see that.
You don't see when Israeli bombs fall on Palestinians,
you don't see rabbis standing alongside mullahs
to condemn it.
And when suicide bombers coming the other
way, you don't see the same thing in the other
direction.
Until that happens, I think people will find
it very difficult to start to resolve these
sort of debates.
And it strikes me that again and again and
again people have not thought of the religious
connotation within it.
One of the great ironies of George Bush in
Iraq was, you had one of the most God-Squadding
presidencies ever.
And yet, they fundamentally sent people into
Iraq without really understanding the difference
between Sunnis and Shias.
There is an element of diplomacy which repeatedly
-- and that in America somewhat quite honorably
wants to push this to one side, but it is
actually a cohesive and big part of modern
politics, I think.
In terms of the divisions at home, in terms
of those culture wars, I think there actually
America is much more useful as an example
to us in Britain.
I think the fundamental division between church
and state in America is incredibly healthy,
and it's something that we should have much
firmer here.
I think U.S.
was right, that what is good for religion
-- in the sense of that split between church
and state -- would be also good for here.
I think the Church of England has nothing
to lose at all by giving up the establishment
cause.
So it is, from my perspective, sort of a difficult
world out there.
I thought at the end, as I said, I would employ
a second cheap trick, which I didn't do at
the beginning.
The second cheap trick is, If you want to
think about the world we're heading towards.
My second cheap trick is to bring in Barack
Obama -- which is the other refuge of every
politician in trouble at the moment, beyond
saying they want to start a conversation.
I think if you want to think about what sort
of religion is the sort of religion which
I think he's going to spread pretty quickly
-- not as much in Europe as it does in America
-- but still with a potency here.
I think, when you think of American Christianity,
you are much, much better thinking of Barack
Obama than you are of George Bush.
Because people, I think, when they had that
idea of American religiosity, they tend to
think of a man who had deep troubles with
drink, and then turned to sort of a vengeful,
difficult, hard executioning version of Texan
religion, and that was what motivated him.
I think actually the Obama story, which is
one of the clever, recently successful, young
-- I forgot what the word is -- metropolitan,
metrosexual, person in Chicago, who thought
that his life was okay but lacking a certain
something.
It lacked a certain sort of meaning, and he
found that in a Chicago church.
That strikes me as a much more plausible,
likely version, of why religion might indeed
grow again in Europe.
Because I don't think believe, to that extent,
that the suburbs of Paris are that different
really to the same suburbs where Obama found
that particular experience.
Anyway, I've employed both my cheap tricks
and talked for just over half an hour, which
is longer than I said.
So I will now open it up to questions.
Thank you.
>> [Clapping] [inaudible]
Q Why do you think that Europe, and certainly
Britain and France, the Nordics, are much
less religious than the rest of the world?
John Micklethwait: I do generally -- I don't
want to sound like a free market fundamentalist
-- but I do think it a lot of it had to do
with that basic idea there is an established
church.
There is one -- if you sit and read Trollop,
and you just see a church which was obsessed
by trying to climb up the different levels.
You know, if you were the vicar of Barchester,
it didn't matter how many people you got in
through the door, that wasn't even remotely
part of your -- all that mattered was you
got on with the deacon of Barchester.
And the same, I think, is true of quite a
lot of the Catholic countries.
It's obviously not just that, because you
could argue there's been a more competitive
market in most European countries since the
beginning of this century.
But I think, by then, the share level to which
religion had been taken out of many of the
areas of kind of competitive society, I think
that did make a difference.
I mean, I think that's the main thing.
It's not the only thing.
You could argue that in general, the general
culture of Europe is now so kind of completely
unreligious, that it's actually quite difficult
for anything to take flower.
But what's interesting is that actually -- there
are bits -- I mean if you go to France, Pentacostalism
is the fastest growing religion.
Like, I don't know the exact statistics.
But from a very small base.
Two million Britons have been on the Alpha
Course, which makes me think -- which is the
one where you see, Is there a meaning to life?
-- and which seems the Alpha Course is sort
of like a kind of Purpose Driven Life for
English people, I suppose is a way of describing
it.
That seems to indicate to me something is
going on.
And if you are very optimistic, from a religious
point of view, you actually look at things
like adult confirmations.
So childhood confirmations have gone down.
Adult confirmations in the Church of England
have gone up.
And you can also look at odd things like pilgrimages.
These are all straws in the wind.
I would personally expect religion in Europe
to go down a bit.
But then, what I describe is the Obama effect
beginning to work -- that people will start
looking for bits of identity and meaning.
The interesting thing to me is that, we don't
make any claim in this book that religion
like that is going to come back in Europe
immediately.
What is interesting is, over the past decade,
I think religion has come back into European
politics in a way that people utterly assumed
it would go away.
The famous Blair quote about, "I don't do
God.”
Or, no, it wasn't Blair, it was Campbell.
"We don't do God on this side of the Atlantic.”
I think that's changed.
Blair himself spends nothing else other than
doing God at the moment.
I think you have Brown, you have -- Sarkozy's
written about religion.
You see the introductions on the East European
ones -- the somewhat crazy Polish brothers
being a good example -- into European politics.
And above all, actually, you see Islam.
Islam is -- I don't buy any of those sort
of Eurabia theories from the neocons -- but
the basic idea is, Islam is posing questions,
putting questions, back into European politics
which people thought had gone.
So for all those reasons, if you were to again
look at ________ articles about politics and
religion ten years ago, and you look at them
now, there's much more stuff going on.
So religion coming back into Europe will take
time.
Religious politics is already there, I think.
[pause]
Q Hi.
You
mentioned the link between foreign policy
and religion.
And the Chinese increasingly becoming confluence
of religions events, from Xinjiang in the
East all the way through to Burma and Nepal.
How do you think this will shape China's foreign
policy?
John Micklethwait: I wouldn't agree.
There was some American conservative meeting
the other night in London where people seemed
to think this was a great hope for China.
I think that would be going too far.
What interests me -- or rather the reason
why it was on my mind was because there was
a well-known American conservative thinker
I came across here.
One of his arguments was that the more -- because
the right wing Americans suddenly got onto
this idea that Christianity is a big thing
in China in a way that Europeans haven't.
Not least because they pour so much money
in there.
The theory he was adopting was, the more Christian
they became, the less sort of bellicose China
would get, which struck me as unlikely, to
the extent that, when you talk to people like
Wang, one of his reasons why he wants China
to adopt Christianity or more Christianity,
he said that China can be even stronger.
He thinks that Christianity was key to America's
success, so therefore make China ever more
powerful.
I think it must make a difference in the following
sense that, if you suddenly have groups of
Christians gathered around places, you've
also got -- it must make some difference to
bits of the foreign policy.
How much I don't know.
I still think that foreign policy tends to
be, nowadays, more driven by nationalism than
it is by religion.
But within China, it could make a big difference.
I didn't talk about it, but I think China
will certainly become the world's biggest
Christian country really, quite quickly.
I think most people reckon it will also become
the world's biggest Muslim country relatively
quickly, because Islam is also doing quite
well there.
So that's another source of joyful conflict.
[pause]
Q Hi. I had two questions.
One was to elaborate on your statement about
the wealthy or the educated comprising a lot
of religious people.
Did you mean in terms of the percentage of
people who are wealthy or educated whereas
poor or uneducated, or actually in numbers?
John Micklethwait: In terms of -- the stuff
to do in terms of Turkey and India was just
sort of anecdotal.
If you look at the people, it's the bureaucratic
bourgeoisie who are moving toward those papers.
In America, my memory is it's both.
If you look at the people who claim to be
evangelicals, they tend to be better educated
than the norm.
If you take a certain norm from American education,
more of them have a college education.
More of them have Ph.D.s, and all that type
of stuff.
I still think within America there is an element
of -- there is one way in which you can query
that figure -- I don't think I'll get too
technical on that.
Basically some of the very conservative, religious
colleges aren't necessarily of the same caliber
as the other ones.
But still, I think, I'll be honest to say,
I've seen a tiny bit in the reception to this
book amongst evangelicals.
Basic American evangelicals are not always
pleased by -- the degree of deliberative criticism
is not always something they terribly like.
Q Do you think it's the same in Islam?
John Micklethwait: Islam, I think the numbers
are more questionable.
Turkey, there's no doubt that what, exactly
the people, you talk to the army people and
the secular heirs of Ataturk.
They are horrified by the idea that exactly
the people they wanted to be profoundly secular
and to steer Turkey away from Ataturk was
very rude about all forms of religious clothing.
Ataturk would have had a nightmare seeing
the leader -- one of his heirs -- standing,
welcoming Obama with his wife wearing a headscarf.
All that stuff was exactly what they didn't
want.
I think in the rest of the Muslim world, it's
more generic.
In Indonesia, there's some evidence that there's
a sort of clever young move back towards it.
Islam is much more difficult to get any kind
of decent polling numbers, because people
are extremely reluctant to say they don't
believe in God.
And I should add, that's true of pretty much
all statistics dealing with religion.
So I try to take it in broad brushes rather
than claiming particular bits.
Q One last question was about corruption.
Do you have any observations on corruption
and religion?
John Micklethwait: Well, I suppose, yeah.
I do have one observation which has to do
with foreign policies.
I think, I am personally always keen on religious,
particularly religious parties, getting -- I'm
not saying I'm keen on saying religious parties
getting into power, it could be misinterpreted
-- but an advantage of religious parties
getting into party and I think a lesson for
the West is, if you have a party like the
AK party, let them get into power.
They should have done the same in Algeria.
Whenever you let a religious party come in
-- and you could argue this is probably true
also of things like with the Muslim Brotherhood
in Egypt -- it's true of arguably of Hamas
in Palestine.
If you let these people get power, they end
up being more like other politicians than
they certainly ever intended to be.
They have to cut deals.
They do -- things like corruption increase.
To some extent, that special degree of moral
superiority, which religious parties can bring
only when they're in opposition.
For the moment, Egypt would be a classic example.
You have the deeply corrupt and not altogether
pleasant Barack regime.
You have the Muslim Brotherhood, which has
some pretty weird ideas, but basically if
you're going to meet them, they do evince
a type of honesty and straightforwardness
which you don't always get from the regime.
______ The Egyptians won't in any way allow
the Muslim Brotherhood to do anything.
The Americans are paranoid about it, because
they sort of see senses a cousin of his brother
in Hamas actually letting them into power.
I think the more power they have, the more
people will begin to see how realistic it
is.
Ahmadinejad's another example of somebody
who claimed to be a religious zealot, but
actually remains there, because he stuffed
ballot boxes.
Q There is talk that the _________ works of
which Dawkins and Sam Harris and everybody
who think along those lines are actually doing
the cause of secularism damage, because it's
drawing people towards religion.
I just wondered if you wanted to comment on
that?
John Micklethwait: I think Dawkins is interesting.
Any time I talk to Dawkins about it, he's
obsessed by the big, scientific pictures.
But actually, he's -- the idea that the sort
of facts.
I said to him, "Look, it's actually interesting.
Religion seems to be doing very well despite
you.”
[laughter] He didn't seem too obsessed by
that.
I think Hitchens is probably more angry about
it than Sam Harris is.
There is an element whereby what always tends
to happen is, once one side exaggerates its
case.
Particularly American politics -- the recent
history of American politics -- has been one
of overreach by one side followed by the other.
You have the 60's, with a profound, liberal,
idiotic term for them, but you have a "leftish"
overreach in the 60's followed by 30, 40 years
of conservatives.
You could argue, with Bush, you then have
a pretty big overreach by the right.
And then, it's now balancing again.
So I would expect something.
Q I have a question about your positive evaluation
of phenomenon and justifying it because people
obviously have more choice.
And I would just say the negative aspect of
it is that, not only there's a choice in what
I spiritually choose to believe, but also
it presents itself as it creeps into the daily
life by, for example, that creationism presents
itself as a choice and alternative to evolution.
And I would argue thus that the tapestry of
different religions that you have and you
can choose between them, somehow also leads
us to believe that basically scientific facts
are being disregarded for the sake of pluralism.
Hence I would still argue in favor of modernity
being understood as secularism in terms of
that religion simply is often challenged by
science and that scientific arguments are
not being taken enough into account by religious
people.
John Micklethwait: I think that's a choice
you have to make.
For my book, pluralism is the greater good
out of those two.
There will be some elements of creationism.
They tend to get pushed back.
You could argue it's worse you say from some
perspectives.
A, you've got the antiscientific lot.
You've also got, as I said earlier -- one
interesting thing about the free market is,
it seems to encourage people with very strong
brands.
I mean, the Pentecostals are probably the
least scientific out of all the Christian
ones, and they're the ones who are doing best.
So there is that risk.
That I'm either -- the one religion that I'm
fundamentalist on the market, but I think
that you have to open up.
But then, I think it's the fundamentally liberal
thing to do.
You give people the chance to understand how
it works.
For me, there's no better thing to lose faith
in Creationism than to visit, I think it's
the Creation Museum in Kentucky, where very
nice people try to explain to you -- and they're
extremely earnest, and some of them even have
rather strange doctrines.
But try to explain to you how, because they
have cram the whole of human history into
2000 years -- you literally go from Adam and
Eve.
And so, like 53 years later, there's dinosaurs
running around really quickly, 'cause I know
those existed.
And then, suddenly we're into Abraham.
And it's patently wrong, and I think anyone
who goes to see it, gets that quite quickly.
Just intellectually, I'm inherently -- I'm
on the, "I feel lucky" part of the thing.
Sorry, Peter, yeah.
Q [inaudible]
John Micklethwait: Google as a religion is
interesting.
I think technology is part of the -- what's
interesting about these people -- what's interesting
about religious people is that, I mean, at
one point we thought about putting this, but
it became difficult to maintain.
You could argue two of the earliest of doctors
of any technology tended to be pornographers.
Churches are remarkably quick in terms of
the way they grab new forms of technology
and push it.
Amongst -- certainly amongst the American
-- if the American Christian thing is the
general dynamic, those are about as protechnology
as it's possible to be.
They're endlessly looking at new ways in order
to get things through.
They're very, very quick on to things like
_________ all those things.
So it's pretty technophile.
Against that, you're right.
There are some elements which are inherently
suspicious of it.
The bit where they get into trouble has more
to do with biology than information technology,
I think.
It's quite interesting actually, but in Africa,
you can argue out of all the dominant religions
there -- and religions grow very quickly in
Africa -- the only religion that now accepts
evolution, the big one is Catholicism, which
is an interesting switch from where it was
around the time of Galileo.
[pause]
Q I was just wondering.
In all the different religious meetings that
you've kind of visited through your research
for the book, what was one experience that
really affected you or kind of stayed with
you?
John Micklethwait: There's two.
I think the exorcism in Brazil was fairly
nonBrazilian -- was a fairly extraordinary
experience.
You go to a sort of normal middleclass -- kind
of middle to working class -- suburb of Sao
Paolo.
You sit there in one of those large churches
that don't have much of an altar.
And then, you think you imagine you got the
wrong time, because there's three exorcisms
a week and it's -- I think it was -- three
o'clock on Wednesday.
I compounded the error by having -- we had
a meeting of all the Latin American correspondents
of The Economist in Sao Paolo that day, and
it ended at lunchtime.
And I foolishly said I was going off to an
exorcism afterwards.
And that sort of, two of them and their girlfriends
said they want to come too.
And you sort of arrive -- It's a bit like
a sort of bad house party arrives in the middle
of this church and you're sitting there in
this large place, and everyone's filing in.
And then, a huge number of housewives come
in with their shopping, children -- you get
the general impression they just dropped off
their laundry, they're picking up their children
from school.
And again, everyone's just sort of sitting
around quite normally.
And then, by within the next barely takes
an hour they're reduced to these quivering
wrecks where you see the same woman who just
walked in beside you with her children is
lying on the floor with people cursing spirits
out of them.
It's a very strong thing -- exorcism -- in
Brazil, because a of people -- a lot of families
who originally came from Africa to some extent
believe that when they left Africa, old tribal
religions cursed them for the fact that they
were being stripped away as slaves to Brazil.
And you see this thing where people are reduced
to this strange shape.
And then what happened, almost the strange
thing were the children sit there play around
in the back, watch their mothers descend to
the floor in this kind of profound emotional
state, and then when the guy brings them back
out of it again, everyone picks up their shopping,
the children all go running around to gather
around their mothers and walk out again.
That extreme of emotion within an hour.
And the odd thing was talking to the pastor
who did it.
Was sort of -- It's almost like talking to
sort of like a surgeon after an operation.
Well, today was quite good.
Five women I think we solved.
It was very kind of it's almost like he's
sitting there making a cigarette.
That was profound.
I also thought that on the less -- other side
of it -- you got a place like Nigeria.
You actually see the religious war is most
intense.
You see Christians, funded by American collection
plate money pushing northwards.
And you see Islam funded by Saudi petrol dollars
coming southwards.
And you just see this smashing together.
And you can go to a place then, a couple of
weeks later, there's a fairly, large-size
massacre.
So there's two.
Q So you talked a lot about the rise of mainstream
religion, and I just wanted to see if you
had any thoughts on the phenomenon behind
like, rising affiliation to sects.
So like, maybe scientology, which has been
a huge uptake in the past few years, and I'm
sure there are quite a few big ones?
John Micklethwait: Well, the truth is, some
of them are sects to the extent that they
drag you in and they never really allow you
out.
I didn't really go into Scientology in perhaps
the level it deserves, not least because they
seem to be the most litigious group of religious
people in the history of the world.
I think what you really -- I mean what de
Tocqueville said when he went to America was,
he said the reason why America does so well
is multiplicity of sects.
This is because what happened at the time
Methodism seems like a sect.
It's the ability without trying desperately
to drag you back to your homeland.
It's the Silicon Valley aspect of American
religion, which you see totally being mimicked
in Asia, in Africa, and in Latin America,
actually, to a large extent, whereby people
come and they set up.
And you can say a bit of East London's East
End as well.
People come, people join one church, and then
they don't really like this bit and so they'd
start a new one.
And if you want a figure who, to me, sort
of symbolizes that form of modern religion
more than anyone else is Thomas Jefferson,
who -- Jefferson went through the Bible and
cut out all the bits he did like and the bits
he didn't and threw out all the others away.
And that was sort of his version of religion.
Well, I'll take this, this, this, this.
And that tends to be how most new sects develop.
The established religions have generally done
quite badly.
It's the newer ones which have kept pushing
forward.
>> Thank you very much.
John Micklethwait: Thank you.
>> [Clapping]